BY WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING ME ON "HANNITY" TONIGHT.
ALSO, VACCINE MANDATES RAMPING
UP FROM COAST-TO-COAST COMEAU
RAISING MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THREATS TO MEDICAL PRIVACY AND
THREAT TO PERSONAL FREEDOM.
GET THIS.
ACCORDING TO THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS EVEN FLOATING
VACCINE MANDATES FOR SAFE TRAVEL
TRAVEL.
OR EVEN CHANGING HOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REIMBURSES TREATMENT
FOR THOSE WHO ARE UNVACCINATED
AND CATCH COVID-19.
HERE FOR A REACTION FROM EPOXIES
CAN SHOOTER MIKE FLYNN,
LARA TRUMP ALONG WITH FOX NEWS
MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR WHO SHOULD
BE CDC DIRECTOR
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO HOLD ONTO THE
SO-CALLED PANDEMIC CRISIS, TAKE
AWAY OUR FREEDOM, ONE SIZE AND
THAT’S WHY YOU HAVE THIS IDEA OF
AN INTERSTATE PASSPORT REQUIRING
EVERYONE TO BE VACCINATED.
WHAT SAY YOU IN THIS?
>> IT’S ABSOLUTELY UNBELIEVABLE.
I ALMOST DIDN’T RECOGNIZE YOU
WITHOUT YOUR HAT ON.
BUT YOU ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
POSTING "HANNITY."
I’M TRYING TO GET MY HAND ON ONE
OF THOSE HATS.
THE REALITY IS THAT IT IS A
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL APPROACH.
WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
IF YOU LOOK AT IS OVERALL IT
REALLY SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A LOT
MORE HERE THAN JUST TRYING TO
KEEP AMERICANS SAFE.
THE REALITY IS THAT THIS IS SO
MUCH ABOUT CONTROL.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO SOCIALIZE A
COUNTRY AND ULTIMATELY TURN
AMERICA INTO A SOCIALIST NATION,
THEN MAYBE YOU GO ALONG AND YOU
SEE JUST HOW FAR YOU CAN PUSH
PEOPLE, HOW LONG CAN YOU LOCK
PEOPLE DOWN, HOW LONG YOU CAN
MAKE EVERYONE WEAR MASKS, HELLO
YOU CAN MAKE OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL
WEAR MASKS.
GOSH, ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO
HAVE A VACCINE PASSPORT TO DRIVE
ON THE INTERSTATE?
IT IS LUDICROUS THAT ANYONE IS
SUGGESTING THIS, ESPECIALLY
WHENEVER WE HAVE A FULLY OPEN
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH OVER
200,000 APPREHENSIONS WE KNOW OF
LAST MONTH ALONE WITH COVID
POSITIVE PEOPLE FLOWING OVER OUR
SOUTHERN BORDERS, GOING
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
YET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
BEING PUNISHED.
IT SEEMS LIKE IF YOU WANTED TO
GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING, QUITE
FRANKLY, JUST COME OVER TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND YOU’VE GOT A
FREE PASS.
>> Leo: ABSOLUTELY.
DR. NICOLE, ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL
DOESN’T WORK FOR ME AS A LAWYER.
I’M SURE FROM MEDICAL
STANDPOINT, I LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT EXEMPTIONS FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MEDICAL CONDITIONS,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALREADY BEEN,
WHO HAVE PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, I LOOK AT RELIGIOUS
FREEDOMS, PERSONAL FREEDOMS, I
LOOK AT THE MEDICAL EXCUSES THAT
MIGHT BE USED BY INDIVIDUALS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT A
DOCTOR THERE.
AND SHOULD IN THIS TYPE OF
DECISION BE IN THE HANDS OF
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS, NOT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
>> LEO, AS YOU SAID, IT’S NOT
BLACK-AND-WHITE.
AND TO LAURA’S POINT
TO LARA’S POINT, NOT ONLY DO WE
DOMINATE THE GLOBAL SUPPLY OF
VACCINES NOT GIVING IT TO
COUNTRIES TO HELP PEOPLE SO WE
CAN LESSEN THE TRANSMISSION
GLOBALLY, BUT YOU START TALKING
ABOUT THESE VACCINE MANDATES.
FIRST OF ALL, IT SHOULD ALWAYS
BE A CONVERSATION BETWEEN A
PHYSICIAN AND THEIR PATIENT.
THE VACCINE MANDATES ARE NOT
UNCOMMON WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTH CARE WORKERS,
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL.
BUT WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT
GOING INTO A RESTAURANT,
INTERSTATE TRAVEL, AND THAT AP
ARTICLE THAT YOU REFERENCED
SAYING THAT THEY ARE STARTING TO
DECIDE THAT MAY BE PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNVACCINATED SHOULD BE
REIMBURSED OR CARED FOR
DIFFERENTLY IF THEY ARE TO
CONTRACT COVID-19?
THAT IS PREPOSTEROUS.
WE AS A COUNTRY SPEND
$200 BILLION EVERY YEAR ON
CIGARETTE SMOKING.
ABOUT NEARLY 500,000 AMERICANS
DIE EVERY YEAR BECAUSE OF
CIGARETTE SMOKING AND TOBACCO
RELATED PRODUCTS.
THAT’S NOT JUST DURING A CRISIS,
THAT’S EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
SO CAN WE STOP LOOKING AT THIS
THROUGH OUR MICROCOSM, ARE
MICROSCOPIC VIEWS QUESTION MIGHT
LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE, WE HAVE
A LOT OF THINGS COSTING OUR
COUNTRY A LOT OF MONEY FROM A
LOT OF THINGS CAUSING DEATH.
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE VACCINES,
IT’S NOT ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL.
THE CDC IS CRIMINAL IN THE SENSE
THAT THEY ARE NOT RECOGNIZING
NATURAL IMMUNITY.
YET MANY OTHER COUNTRIES AT THIS
POINT HER NECK AND
WHO RECOGNIZE NATURAL IMMUNITY
NOT
EFFECTIVE AS THE VACCINES BUT
EVEN BETTER IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ISRAELI DATA.
ON TOP OF THAT, OUTSIDE THE
UNITED STATES YOU DON’T HAVE
CHILDREN BEING MAST IN SCHOOLS
BECAUSE THERE’S NO DATA SHOWING
THE BENEFIT OF THAT ACTUALLY
OUTWEIGHS THE HARM THAT IT
POTENTIALLY COULD DO TO THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
THE UNITED STATES ACTUALLY HAS
TO START FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE
AND THE NEED TO GET AWAY FROM
THEIR NARRATIVE AND THIS MYOPIC
PUSH TO JUST VACCINATE EVERYONE.
WE HAVE TO THINK OF PEOPLE AS
INDIVIDUALS.
NOT NECESSARILY ALWAYS ABOUT THE
COLLECTIVE.
>> Leo: I AGREE 100%.
I FIND THE POLITICAL
GAMESMANSHIP BY THE DEMOCRATS
OFFENSIVE AND I’M TALKING ABOUT
HOW THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN
GOING AFTER GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
IN FLORIDA.
I FIND IT OFFENSIVE THEY ARE
GOING AFTER HIM.
IT’S PURE POLITICS.
WHAT’S WORKING IN FLORIDA,
DEMOCRATS DO NOT LIKE IT AND
THEY ARE PLAYING POLITICAL
GAMES.
HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> THEY ARE TERRIFIED BY THE
FACT THAT RON DeSANTIS HAS
DONE SUCH A GREAT JOB WITH
COVID -- I’M COMING TO YOU RIGHT
NOW FROM THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
I JUST MOVED HERE BECAUSE OF THE
GREAT JOB THAT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS HAS DONE.
IT IS A FREE AND OPEN STATE.
BUT TO YOUR POINT ABOUT IT,
THINK BACK TO HOW JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS HAVE NO PROBLEM
POLITICIZING THE VACCINE FOR
THEIR BENEFIT DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
REMEMBER THAT, THEY WERE ALL
NERVOUS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
DEVELOPING A VACCINE.
NOW THAT THEY ARE IN CHARGE,
THEY WANT EVERY SINGLE PERSON TO
GET IT.
WHICH ONE IS IT, JOE AND KAMALA?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SADLY ARE
THE ONES HURT BY THIS, WE ARE
THE ONES BEING FORCED INTO A
BOX, FORCED TO DO SO MANY
THINGS.
BUT THEY KNOW THAT THEIR
APPROACH ISN’T WORKING.
AMERICANS ARE FED UP WITH IT.
LOOK AROUND THE WORLD.
THE U.K., FRANCE, AUSTRALIA,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE PUSHING BACK
ON MANDATES,, ON LOCKDOWNS, ON
ALL OF IT.
IT’S GOING TO COME FOR JOE AND
KAMALA HARRIS AFTER A WILD.
>> I’VE GOT A LEO 2.0 TERRELL